[Musik]
wer hat die kokosnuss wer hat die
kokosnuss werte kokosnuss geklaut hat
hallo herzlich willkommen in ein oder
zwei ließ welt herzlich willkommen war
hier möchte blackout herzlich willkommen
in sallys welt herzlich willkommen zum
tennis welt
hallo
herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
schreibt mal gern richtig ist
hey ich bin kreativ um wird jedenfalls
ich bin echt verwirrt egal jedenfalls
möchte ich heute einen guglhupf backen
und zwar einen raffaello gugelhupf weil
ich einfach und gebäck mit kokosnuss
echt vermisst habe und ich muss sagen so
gar nicht wir hatten uns schon länger
mal vorgenommen raphael los zu benutzen
deswegen ich keine produktplatzierung
selber gekauft muss man immer dazu sagen
meine güte jetzt machen wir einen
leckeren google ob ihr könnt da einfach
eine form eurer wahl verwenden und das
kam ziemlich glaube ich schon ziemlich
lecker ich zeige euch noch kurz die
zutaten dafür verwende 250 gramm butter
200 gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt
und gute prise salz fünf eier dürfen
gern raum warm sein also
zimmertemperatur haben 400 gramm mehl
und vier teelöffel backpulver oder
verwendet das bak mail 80 gramm
kokosraspeln 200 gramm saure sahne 100
milliliter mineralwasser also sprudel
und natürlich raffaello süßigkeiten dann
nehme ich zuerst die weiche butter die
kommt hier in die rührschüssel ihr könnt
gerne ein handrührgerät benutzen ich
muss halt sagen manchmal nämlich ein
handrührgerät wenn ich denke kommt das
zeige ich euch jetzt dem handrührgerät
aber für mich ist halt schon oft
einfacher die küchenmaschine zu benutzen
weil ich dann nämlich wenn die dann fünf
minuten rührt immer in der zeit schnell
sauber nach und da war es noch nicht und
nächste zutaten und so und dann ist es
halt einfach also weiche butter zucker
vanille extrakt und salz in eine
rührschüssel geben
[Musik]
und dann verrät er die zutaten hierfür
etwa vier bis fünf minuten schön weiß
cremig
ich glaube ich pack's lang einfach schon
mal die raffael los aus ich muss dazu
sagen darf ich kritisch sein darf ich
finds halt
ich will nicht kritisch sein aber
manchmal kann sich auch die einzel
verpackung sparen mittlerweile ist sie
doch eh alle also für was die einsaat
typen kann man doch alles in so eine
schöne nachhaltige tüte die auch schöne
da sind übrigens
230 gramm drin ich brauche aber nur 200
problem löst
natürlich um deine kamera schmutzig
[Musik]
wenn die eier zucker masse dann schön
weiß cremig ist gebt ihr dazu nicht alle
auf einmal sondern immer schön einzeln
eine halbe minute einrühren damit sich
alles wieder homogen vermischt und dann
erst das nächste
[Musik]
jetzt ist die masse verrührt die raffael
los habe ich jetzt auch schon mit dem hk
zerstampft so bleibt die mandel in der
mitte ganz wenn ihr die mandel aber auch
verkleinert haben wollt dann solltet ihr
sie fein hacken oder im mixer
zerkleinern und jetzt gibt dir einfach
die restlichen zutaten im wechsel dazu
ihr wisst sobald mail dazu kommt darf
man nicht mehr so lange rühren ansonsten
wird der kuchen nicht schön luftig und
locker sondern eher speckig und matschig
dh es gibt es mail und kokos und dann
die zwei flüssigen zutaten einfach dazu
rühren nur kurz und dann den rest
[Musik]
habe ich hier meinen wunderbaren
lockeren schönen tag und da kommen jetzt
diese raffaello krümelchen rein die muss
ich so ein bisschen auflockern muss ich
sagen denn ich habe die show stark dass
stampft und dann rühre ich das gleich
einfach kurz unter
[Musik]
und dann hättet ihr eure vormittag
transpower am besten
und darauf achten dass ihr die dose
einfach senkrecht halt nicht so denn
dann entweicht das gas und das ganze fed
bleibt in der flasche ist das ganz
wichtig dass gibt es übrigens jetzt auch
deutschlandweit in jeder lidl filiale
könnte gern mal die augen offen halten
und jetzt kann ich hier den wundervollen
teig einfüllen und das ganze im
vorgeheizten backofen backen ihr könnt
entweder 170 grad ober unterhitze und
dann so ungefähr ein bisschen länger als
eine stunde oder falls ihr habt einen
bug sensor das zeige ich aber gleich ein
backofen
[Musik]
reicht es doch immer gerne hier am rand
so ein bisschen hoch dann verteilt sich
der teig nämlich schön gleichmäßig
dann erkläre ich euch jetzt mal den
wachsen so kommt man hier
also kuchen rein der ofen ist es noch
aus und auch kalt jetzt schalte ich ab
dann gehe ich auf menü
es ist das ist der bug assistent dann
könnt ihr auswählen kuchen drückt dann
noch mal hier auf den kuchen und könnt
auswählen zwischen kuchen in form kuchen
auf dem backblech oder eben andere
kuchen arten ich habe hier den kuchen in
form und dann wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr
gerne hier noch auf den tipp gehen da
steht dann form auf rost höher 2 denn
der bug sensor misst im backofen den
sauerstoffgehalt und die feuchtigkeit
und dann schalten sie den ofen
automatisch ab wenn der kuchen gar ist
und dann ist wirklich perfekt und kam
aus dem ofen genommen werden das heißt
ihr braucht keine stäbchen problem ist
nicht darauf achten könnt einfach so
lang
putzen was anderes
[Musik]
was passiert jetzt richtig schön perfekt
aus es fertig gebacken und ich lasse die
ziele kurz etwa 10-15 minuten in der
form abkühlen stürzten dann heraus und
dann geht es weiter mit dem schönen
raffaello club
[Musik]
und ich werde jetzt hier oben mal
das ganze wegschneiden dann ist schon
mal gerade das mache ich generell
eigentlich ganz gern damit der kuchen
gerade steht und nicht irgendwie schief
ist obwohl der als gerade still wird
aber er kommt nicht raus
wenn ihr da so ein großes brotmesser
nehmt brot kuchen messer was auch immer
dann könnte wirklich das ganze schön
gerade wegschneiden
doch das sieht richtig gut aus meine
güte ist gut geworden es kommt doch
wieder
kinder einfach
[Musik]
so wird das gemacht
ja es ist oft so wenn halt der kuchen
über die form backt dann klebt doch
irgendwo fest wenn es gerade weg
schneidet ich zwar irgendwo schade dass
dann also der boden fehlt aber
andererseits finde ich hat man halt
immer ein schöner abschluss
unwahrheit glas zum probieren ob der
kuchen schmeckt zu widerrufen kann kann
man direkt so eine geschmacksprobe
machen so
sehr gut
der ist so schon super aber der bekommt
von mir noch nicht schon mit lasur
glück gehabt sonst wär's rumkugeln wurde
habe ich jetzt die zutaten für die
glasur und dekoration ich hab mir
überlegt entweder könnt ihr eine glasur
aus frischkäse oder sauer creme und
puderzucker zubereiten oder er macht
eine weiße schokoladen lassen und das
werde ich jetzt machen deswegen habe ich
jetzt hier schon eine weiße kuvertüre
dann nehme ich ja immer gerne die
callebaut weil es einfach muss ich sagen
die beste qualität hat dann etwas
kokosfett zum weitermachen dekorateure
passt auch geschmacklich hervorragend
kokos chips und raphael los natürlich
und jetzt solltet ihr die kuvertüre am
besten auf jeden fall temperieren das
heißt vor kristallisieren ich habe jetzt
hier auch schon mal einen teil also zwei
drittel geschmolzen
über dem warmen wasserbad
und kann jetzt hier den rest dazu geben
[Musik]
wenn es beim geschmolzen ist kommt dann
auch das kokosöl mit rein und falls es
noch mal kurz erwärmen müsst könnt ihr
es gerne noch mal aufs wasser bat setzen
oder mit seinem heißluft 5 als sie einen
sonderpreis wird noch zur ecke in der
kirche aber ich sag's euch das ist
wirklich praktisch wenn man viel mit
schokolade oder kuvertüre arbeitet dann
ist es praktisch dass ich auch nicht
viel günstiger als in temporär gerät und
man kann sie echt gut brauchen
deswegen nacht nicht aus und man kann
sieht sich kollege damit machen bist du
noch silvester
dieses die schokoladen decke
jetzt hast du noch mal
[Musik]
dann nehmt euch bitte euren kopf schön
auf einem abkühlen gitter darunter ein
blech damit die übrige schokolade wieder
aufgefangen werden kann natürlich und
dann kommt die glasur schön gleichmäßig
obendrauf
[Musik]
perfekt
diese schön aus richtig schön abend die
übrigen kuvertüre und kokosraspeln okay
ich jetzt gerade bisschen übertrieben
die werde ich aber gleich mit
cornflakes verrühren und dann habe ich
schock rossis und natürlich noch meine
kurven reste und dann mache ich noch
kleine bändchen draus
[Musik]
ich habe einfach noch die restliche
kuchen masse zerbröselt dann die weiße
schokolade und die kokosraspeln dazu
geknetet und mit bisschen frischkäse
verfeinert und jetzt kann ich bei mais
portionierer mit dem kleinen kleine
bällchen formen und wie bei einem
raffaello einfach einem wandel in den
mittelstädten und dann nur noch in
kokons tauchen
[Musik]
schneiden wir den raffaella curiel mal
an und ich hole jetzt einen kokosnuss
nicht habe
denn max hallo
was heißt wieder thomas ich habe ja auch
so
macht man
das kind unter so und der unterkiefer
hat auf 3
es ist schön dass sie da sind drei
eckchen also wieder schön gesagt was ich
bin echt wie diesen liebhabers kokos und
ananas allgemein ich trinke auch aus
diesen zu einer richtigen coup ist ja
dass man auch
aber nur im urlaub bei krieg die daheim
nicht auf aber es gibt jetzt extra diese
dieses oft kokosnuss dinge die nicht
mehr diese harte schale haben
ich habe es probiert
deswegen
vielleicht zu erklären da gibt es drei
öffnungen und eine davon in schweich
allgemein ja bei jeder kokosnuss hat
drei so löcher dann habe ich immer die
raser erwischt ich las dass den lieber
am strand machen wir um
banana banana so laufen dem warum
wir noch vor vielleicht mehr kriegen
da probiert mal einen kuchen nicht
vorgenommen meine raffaello kugel das
auch gemacht und ja durchaus kuchen
resten cool ich habe sogar eine mandel
rein wie bei der echten nachteil
[Musik]
das hat auch so ein bisschen bounty
weiter aber ich glaube es ist komisch
muss
[Musik]
darf ich davon auch einen
aber eine angabe
ist gut sehr gut
hast du schon mal ausgepackt
ja aber nicht so kompliziertere sachen
sondern hier ist einfach ich habe früher
viel hat bei uns die der donau
weltmeister
die lange arbeit schon bei uns mit fast
zwei jahre und wie oft hab ich was von
dir gebacken und gegessen
oder oder oder
der max back die donauwelle
donnerstag bei harpstedt album sorry
wartet zwar steigen aber ich habe nicht
gesagt ich bin es nicht wahr und die aus
dem
weltmeister
[Musik]
also ich halte es gerne machen aber es
gibt keine garantie dass es schmeckt wir
machen ja schreibt man gerne in die
kommentare ob ihr mann wollte max hier
für uns eine donauwelle macht als
donauwellen meister oder und bis dahin
könnt ihr diesen rafael okotie
ausprobieren ich weiß es gibt ja
menschen die mögen kokosnuss also ich
weiß es gibt auch welche die mögen
keinen kokosnuss ihr könnt ja gern mal
schreiben ob wir dazu gehört oder nicht
also das rezept gibt es wie immer auf 6
- blog de oder in der app die der max
mit sicherheit auch runtergeladen hat
und in seinem favoriten gespeichert hat
weil er wird alle seine lieblingsrezepte
von mir im gespeichert eine
einkaufsliste erstellt und dann per
whatsapp teilen kann gut mit und so
traten kann man sogar eigene zutaten und
dinge noch nicht
mitmachen die donauwelle dann ist
hoffentlich damit einiges wieder gut und
bin ladens die app gleich
ich hatte wirklich mal auf dem handy auf
irgendeinem
so viele handys weil er einen eigenen
youtube kanal hat und da stellt er halt
handys und alles mögliche vor und
deswegen hat er ständig neue handys
deswegen ich verzeihe dir
last wird auf allen
[Musik]